رؤيه المنتادين الصينيين في سماء الولايات
المتحده عكرت صفوا الاجواء الصينيه
الامريكيه المعكره اصلا ففيما الاتهامات
بالتجسس تساقط الصين تتمسك الاخيره بروايه
المنطاد المدني المتفلت من اراضيها بفعل
احوال جويه سيئه حيث اكد البنتاجون رصدا
منطاد اخر فوق امريكا اللاتينيه دون تحديد
موقعه بدقه ووفق موقع 24
المنطاد قطع امريكا اللاتينيه شرقا باتجاه
المحيط الاطلسي الجنوبي قبل اختفاء اثره
واشنطن وعقبه خلق المنطاد الصيني الاول
لمجالها الجوي ارجاء وزير خارجيتها
زياره للصين يؤمن منها تخفيف حده التوتر
وتجنب التصعيد زياره هي الاولى لوزير
خارجيه امريكي للجمهوريه الشعبيه منذ خمس
سنوات
لقد تحدثت مع مدير مكتب الشؤون الخارجيه
واخبرته انني ساؤجل سفر المحطط له في عطله
نهايه الرجوع الى الصين للاسف الصيني
لحادثه وصفتها بكين بغير المقصوده لم تؤثر
ايجابا في عدم الغاء الزياره رغم ان
الاعتذار جاء اولا فوزاره الخارجيه
الصينيه اكدت ان المنطاد الاول خرج عن
مساره المحدد بسبب تيار هوائيه لافته الى
استغلال اعلامي وسياسي للحدث واتخاذه
ذريعه لمهاجمتها وتشويه صورتها
الخارجيه الامريكيه تلقفت مشاعر الاسف في
خانه اخذ العلم فقط مبقيه على تصريحاتها
بان العمل يمثل انتهاكا واضحا للسياده
وبالتالي يقوض الغرض من رحله بلينكن وابدت
املها في ابقاء قنوات الاتصال مفتوحه مع
بكين ازمه من طرد المراقبه التي اثارت
حفيظه الجمهوريين قد تتواصلوا مع توقعات
ببقائه فوق الاراضي الامريكيه لبضعه ايام
اضافيه علما بان المناطيط تعد من اقدم
وسائل الرقابه والتجسس واكثرها جراه ليس
فعاليه الاقمار الصناعيه لكنها تهدف حاليا
لجس نبض الامريكيين ومعرفه رد فعلهم وفق
خبراء